so I'm very fascinated about where you
are in your life because I genuinely
believe the world is telling you the
reverse of the right information when
you're this young the number one thing
you should do is the most high-risk
behavior of your life you know to me
this is exactly when you should go live
in Bali for a year this is exactly when
you try to become Beyonce this is
exactly when you do the highest risk the
biggest reason that kids like people
become unhappy is they try to attract
they're playing life in Reverse the only
things that you could be dealing with
are either debt or expectations of your
parents and what your parents and
society do is tells you to do the lowest
risk maneuver the number one thing you
should be thinking about is the highest
risk behavior around the thing that you
think is gonna make you the happiest
which is gonna go spitting in the face
of everybody from your parents to the
school you're in till your friends and
what they thought and maybe even to
yourself an hour ago
self-awareness is the most important
without even knowing any of you I'm sure
your love affair with your music skill
craft has evolved through your life
right and this is exactly the time where
some of you are looking at me and be
like do I even love this [ __ ] anymore
another huge recommendation I would give
you is go work literally for free or
like minimum wage or as little as
possible for the exact human being that
you aspire to be at 23 24 25 you should
go work for Vera Wang for free and then
at night you should work at Whole Foods
on the night shift
and you should work live with eight
people so you only need to make 300
bucks but everybody does the reverse
they take a job that they don't even
like for $3,000 more I have a lot of
empathy for people in debt I have way
less for people not in debt because then
they're letting the Machine parents
society dictate their lives who they
then later resent
because they followed their path not
yours but like getting some [ __ ] job
to like pay off the debt and
moonlighting as your passion it's the
reverse don't buy a new pair of Supremes
or like a new handbag or take a nice
trip to Coachella otherwise you get
stuck you're just stuck in perpetuity or
do that I don't give a [ __ ] but don't
not do what you want to do I do not have
your profession do you can either work
for somebody that you want to become or
try your Lee [ __ ] you're talking to
somebody who's ridiculously happy
because he never played in the system I
was a terrible student even though every
immigrant shouldn't have been right I
worked for my dad's liquor store and
built up a family business for my family
so I made no money I'd go different you
know my narrative is very tricky
a lot of people like oh but your dad I'm
like I built my dad's business for him
and left with nothing at 34 you know but
I was happy I didn't care that my
friends went to Wall Street and got a
BMW I was I had self-esteem I didn't
need a cool apartment to get girls I
didn't even want to get girls I'm so
busy working on what I was passionate
about to be frank you know if you're
great at something and you're [ __ ]
passionate about it you should have the
best life and people [ __ ] it up I didn't
I did everything wrong for 13 years
which made me win and stay happy even
though you're you're studying a field
bit is related to what you want your
career to be they're still in classes
and completing those classes takes up
takes a lot of effort and time right
there they're putting classes that have
nothing to do with the future right yeah
okay that my personal point of view on
that is to only allocate the amount of
time and passion that allows you to get
to the next place you need to what I'm
saying is whatever the lowest grade you
can get in that class that allows you to
continue in advance is what you should
aim for a lot of people's DNA only makes
them strive towards perfection which
eats up an allocation of time that I
think you should be deploying on other
things
so if you're telling me right now you're
self-aware enough to know this [ __ ]
accounting class or whatever [ __ ] you go
to is not gonna mean anything to me you
know there's only a couple variables one
there's the school's rules of what you
need to get to pass and graduate right
then the only other variables are your
own kind of you know self-worth of how
you deliver it in a class environment
and then the only other variable is your
parents or anybody else you respect
ambition above your grade point average
those last two don't mean anything the
first one does it's the rules you can't
get an F in this or you can't move on
but if you can get a C I just don't know
I'm saying least amount of resistance
against your own self-awareness and
passions that allows you to then get you
know all of a sudden you can imagine
when you're getting an hour back a day
from studying on some class that's some
[ __ ] but you know yourself they can
get a C instead of an a now you have an
hour to make Instagram content that may
actually lead to the thing that you want
to do for a living
listen I'm recording this so every
[ __ ] parent on earth can see it
because if you're a great parent you are
your kid to be happy not to get a grade
point average that you can go brag at it
at the Country Club that's to me the
line in the sand of great parents versus
good parents versus bad parents and I'm
thrilled to say that
so if you're put on situation where you
have to choose between two big
opportunities you'll never know what the
alternative would have been you pick one
and you never ever ever even consider to
look back because you have to understand
why let me I always play this out let's
say when you go to heaven they can show
you what would have happened because
that's the only way you'd ever see what
people don't understand is Oh Basha you
made the wrong call you should have went
to grad school instead of that
opportunity where this company instead
of that company and it was perfect and
you rose like a phoenix and you were the
head of all sound and everything went
great but then you had to go to Virginia
on business and you got hit by a car and
you died at 31
that's life so to like look at two ideas
and think you can practically make a
good decision is laughable
literally flip a coin just pick the one
that feels better right that second and
make it about you because usually what
kids struggle with is the decision they
want to do
versus the decision that they think
they're supposed to do based on the
other voices you want to get real happy
have the conversation that you actually
want to have with the seven people
you're closest to tell them the truth of
how you feel about everything that will
change your life what you don't know is
that even if they are pissed at you and
like say who the [ __ ] do you think you
look no matter how much they [ __ ] on you
the level of respect will be real that's
where it's at and honestly I'm not
telling you to go call your mom and say
go [ __ ] yourself but I am saying that
the next the transition to the happiest
place you can go is if you can be
self-fulfilled within yourself beyond
pathetic for your parents not mad you
know a lot of you probably have this
either your grandparents your parents
paid a lot of sacrifices to give you
this chance that's their framework on
the world but you shouldn't be paying
the price for that because you're living
in a different reality it doesn't mean
you're disrespectful some of you don't
have death because your parents paid
like theirs you should be thankful and
empathetic they should not live your
life
for them because I'll tell you how it's
gonna play out brother so you'll be okay
for the next ten years and then you have
40 years of resentment and regret and a
bad relationship parents a lot of time
to see this confident get mad at me but
then I talked to them and I'm like you
may be upset with me now
email me in 2037 when you don't when
your kids have no ammo on you to believe
you for their unhappiness I'm always
worried about your guys backgrounds -
are you living your life for the Machine
or for your parents and not because I
want to razz parents it's cuz I want you
to actually have a good relationship
with your parent I'm just willing to
have a little pain from 22 to 28 guys
the only thing I'm hedging against is
for rent that's when you need to be
careful of and that's what most people
do they build a life that leads to
regret
nobody old and about to die talks about
what they did they talk about what they
do
and you're in the best spot right now
you're the best buy you'll ever be
straight up this is the time to be most
song thoughtful but everybody wants you
to figure out your life now
your parents don't have their lives to
get out this is the time to taste and
put yourself into positions you could do
everything wrong for the next 10 years
of your life and the youngest [ __ ]
and have unlimited time to do anything
you want like I don't know it's to tell
you you can do everything wrong this is
when you need to be ridiculous
[Music]